we realized that there were so many
other genres that were taken
away from our genre and we weren't
benefiting from it you know
you see a reggaeton is a billion dollar
industry afrobeat
also is a um you know
it is influenced heavy by dancehall and
their billion dollar industry
why can't we as as jamaican people and
jamaican artists get together and
educate ourselves and help each other
to actually um own a piece of this
[Music]
talk to us a little bit about how this
legendary dancehall trio came together
tell us the story behind the song um i
was the one who
initiated the whole thing well first i
reached out to shaggy
um to do a song with him and that's
where it started from
i went to the studio we were saving two
different rhythms and tracks and
that's when i heard the chorus on god
only because it was already recorded and
from the moment i heard for us
i was like this is it this is all me my
bad right yes
when i recorded my verse and it was
coming together i was
i i started to say can you imagine
how historic it would be if sean paul
was on the song
because you know me extra miles i pushed
the envelope what i really love about it
was the moment
we said yes and we sent the song to sean
paul
when then the next day he said back in
first he was ready and so i know that
yeah this is a hit because you know sean
paul heard
but i heard with the moment that some
dropped so
i felt so excited and i still feel
excited right now and i'm just humbled
to know that i have two legends on my
track on my album coming up
yeah and shout out to you girl for
saying what you want and going after it
definitely jackie and sean paul
is for you okay so i've learned about
spice through loving hip-hop
but i feel like now she's rising to a
new level of stardom
people are learning about the dancehall
queen right
how does it feel to support her as she
rises to this new level in her career
for me
i'm a fan of spun i'm a fan of spice um
so is my wife uh you know we've been
looking forward to
seeing her make this move in terms of
put her body away together and put all
the album
and so you know for me it's an exciting
time
and also uh you know it was big up to
shaggy for
for stepping in um and getting the
executive producing
done uh it was something that needed to
happen you know sometimes you have
you have the gas you have the fire but
just nobody didn't do this park yet and
and i think that um the relationship
that shaggy and spikes have
is is a testament to that you know we're
getting done
so uh when you see the album coming out
again this month right
the line is the third year july 30th
this is her album 10 it comes out july
30th with an assist from shaggy and sean
paul
on the song go down there spice to add
on to that shaggy i love the story about
how this
album came to be how you jumped on as an
executive producer
can you tell our audience a little bit
about that well you know
just like sean said you know there was
not a body of work from her
you know we know of spice for the years
so you might learn about her from from
love and hip-hop but
you know the dancehall community nora is
the queen of dancehall you know i mean
uh
loving hip-hop really just brought her
to uh an audience that probably wasn't
familiar with dancehall as much
or of her and dancehall um
so you know we needed her to to have
that body of work out
to support the amount of years she had a
lot of singles
and uh she told me that she had some
issues with the record company and you
know she was signed in a
in a deal that wasn't a very favorable
deal so i just kind of went in and have
a conversation with them
and kind of came up with a win-win
situation that worked
and um you know and uh we all sat down
and hashed it out and came up with a
game plan and
and executed the game plan and you know
so far but they were nicely
shaggy
we're diplomatic you went into the
conversation with shaggy just asking for
a song
and he came back authoring an album with
a whole album
like when does that happen you know
one more immediate reaction to that i
mean
like i said me always are extra after
other things but
i mean i personally felt like when i
went to the studio
to do the song i don't think shaggy and
i have ever been in a studio
before together so i think he was amazed
by my talent become a very very
different you know he's a different
breeder artist
[Laughter]
you know what um i i i gave her i gave
her four songs
to do okay and when she came in
and she knocked the four songs there so
quickly
that i was taken aback of how
quickly she did them how quickly she
learned them
and how well she executed them
and i had to do very little as far as
direction to get what i want and right
there i knew i was gonna have a lot of
fun so
and it was worth it and i think the
world just needed to know so sorry to
interrupt what i had
hear with the legend
well shaggy you mentioned in an
interview that you wanted go down there
to be a song about unity for the
dancehall
genre for those who aren't that familiar
with dan's hall and reggae
why is the message of unity needed right
now
in the genre i think they we needed to
set an example and sean
and i have you know we're the two uh top
streamers
in dance so we have an incredible
platform and and spice
also has an incredible platform so
i just thought that us coming together
as
just three dancehall artists with a
dancehall director like
j will on a dancehall label like vp
really um sends a message that we could
do it
on our own if we just unite you know i
mean if we just come together and help
each other like a crab in the barrel is
how about the crabs get on each other's
shoulder to get out
you know what i'm saying so that's kind
of that's kind of what i wanted to
to do with this and and and you know
sean a lot of people don't know that
sean and i
have had these conversations at two
three o'clock in the morning
throughout covid just talking about
business and talking about
how you know we could unify it and how
we could
become a force because we realized that
there were so many other genres that
were taken
away from our genre and we weren't
benefiting from it you know
you see a reggaeton is a billion dollar
industry afrobeat also is a
um you know it's influenced heavy by
dancehall and their
billion dollar industry and why can't we
as as jamaican people and jamaican
artists get together and educate
ourselves and help each other
to actually um own a piece of this
you know i'm saying and capitalize it
and let our country
capitalize on on it let there be a
legacy
um throughout a a monetary
legacy for for um dancehall and reggae
artists
uh that are older ones you know there's
so many dancehall artists that are
that are old or reggae artists that are
gonna die broke
you know and and their body of work is
owned by somebody
else you know some entity that has
nothing to do with it so a lot of these
things bother me and
sean and i discuss these things over and
over and over again and we're we're
blessed tim and i are blessed
to have somehow maneuvered through the
game and and
and you know be financially okay but
there's a lot of this
that aren't nothing bros
yeah but with even though through the
battles on the bruises we still
somehow came out you know to to where we
will be okay we just want that for
everybody else we want that for somebody
like spikes we want so if we could share
our platform
and and just get together and just show
that unity and say everybody come come
on board for this
i think i think it's incredible it's an
important thing to celebrate and say yo
i believe in these producers i believe
in these artists um
let me work with them and show the world
are the people who are focusing on my
platform
that these are the people who i revere
and respect
you know i mean and that's a start
yeah well sean paul your album's coming
out soon right
yeah i won't called scorcher coming out
this year i'm
releasing my second single the first one
was a more dancer oriented single but
the next one
is with ty dolla sign and it's more as i
said
more traffic dancer kind of
or even even a pop kind of dancehall
aspect to it they call only fans and
that will drop
on the 13th of august
and then you have features with sia gwen
stefani you have some really some really
good features
what what type of what type of vibe can
fans expect from the song with gwen
stefani like what can you tease
oh that song will bring stefan it
features another jamaican
female artist called shancilla that song
is a lover's rock reggae song
so it's gonna be quite different now
we've heard gwen stefani do reggae
before
but uh you know with it's another trio
uh and a great record coming out i would
say probably
late or this year or maybe into the
album cycle next year
uh since we're gonna drop the album
later on
well i'm excited for that every time
like when i see you i think of i'm
i'm still in love with you my same type
of record
that video oh
and then baby boy of course is there any
any future where we could possibly see a
baby boy part 2
or another collaboration with you and
beyonce oh yeah i would love to work
with her again
she's such a phenomenal artist and um
you know i'm open to doing it i think
i'm the only person that's done
a song with the three destinies children
so i did with beyonce i also did a song
called how deep is your love with
kelly and also michelle i mean did a
christian son believe it or not she
asked me to do one and i was like yeah
for sure
um my faith is strong and i did one with
her so
it was a pretty good look and i i'm open
to doing more work with beyonce
just as you asked for sure i love that
well shaggy you have always been just
a symbol of fun positivity good vibes
and it's been what 21 years since it
wasn't me dropped
you're still notable in the industry
everyone still loves you and admires you
what do you attribute your longevity to
if you could attribute it to something
what would it be it's hard yeah you're
right to attribute it to
any one particular things are real is
really hard but
um i think i i attribute it to me not
um being bored
i'm allergic to boredom you know so i
always i always try to
change and try something new and try
you know different styles and change my
voice up and switch my music up and
you know so um you know i just look i
just look
for that that thing and always try to
keep my finger on the pulse of what's
going on and
and come up with something that has a
great story to it you know and
and try and stay in the in the now you
know i have you know
it's not like you you're oh i have to be
running the now you know but i just need
to be
um i don't have to leave the now but i'm
just got to be in the now
you know and understand why for sure you
know
absolutely absolutely she is now she's
now right now you know so it but it's
good to be in that
just to be in in the circle of that and
just you know um
i i never sit down and worry about what
i've done from before you know it's oh
yeah
you know it wasn't me or whatever you
know that's then it's really about what
i'm doing now and how i do it now and
how do i maneuver
myself through the i love it
well you mentioned it wasn't me with
them but i have a question because
during my research
you said that women groups after the
song dropped you were getting hate
messages from women groups
yeah for the song it wasn't me
what were they saying it was it was even
banned
um it was banned it was all these bands
and women groups and you know because it
was they thought it was a cheating
but it's actually an anti-cheese
cheating record
if they listen down to the end of the
song it says i'm gonna tell her that i'm
sorry for the things that i've done you
might think that you're a player but
you're completely lost
uh so simply means that you know the
song isn't really con
um condoning cheating it's actually
saying yeah you're gonna
you're kind of a loser
so that's that's what it was so it was a
misunderstanding
i think as the song got better then we
did a research and realized that
after the record became number one it
was huge that majority of the fans who
was
who was buying the records were women
[Music]
winning